All right here. We are at the Dallas improv.
This is my first standup set back in like 84, uh,
84 days. I got,
I just put a special out to all my materials gone.
It'd be one thing that I could come back on stage is jumping in my old act,
but I just put out an act. I put out on YouTube, it's all out there.
So now I got no material and no skills. So I wrote just a ton of.
I got Corona, I got riots. I got anal. I mean, you name it.
And, uh, I'm terrified. I'm rusty. And I have new material.
That's not fleshed out. This is going to be a disaster. And uh,
I want you to all watch it and be there with me, but this is going to be ugly.
But the witness, a big bomb folks. Yeah,
the pandemic's got nothing on this show right here is going
to be bad. And we got 25% capacity. You know, the whole thing is,
this is just a bad situation. It's good to get ugly, Phil.
Let's see what happens.
Yay comedy. Huh? All right. We're really doing it. Thanks for coming out.
Cleavage, shoulders. How are you doing there? I love the hoops.
Love a lady with hoops.
You can always tell a crazy woman is by the size of her hoops. Right?
That's where this comes from. Somebody write that down.
Just thought of that. Oh right. And don't worry. I'm not cheating here.
These just because I've drawn. Here you go.
Eh. Yep. Yep. And I hope I'm not, I don't mean to offend anybody.
If you are offended, just, you know, kill yourself.
But like now you're allowed to be offended. I'm just joking. But you know, uh,
Hey, welcome back speaking. And taking a. Uh,
ah,
worked so hard on that phone, Booz joking, but I was like, yeah, that's cute.
Then I do the joke.
That's why comedy is a kick in the taint that, but it's honest.
I appreciate the honesty. You're all good eggs.
Big fan. I might've heard it.
Thank you. Hey,
thanks for coming out. Get it here. There we go.
No touching tattoos. I'll call you.
I appreciate you. Thank you. Thanks for watching and a hair.
There's a bunch of schools right by my apartment.
I live in New York and all there's all these schools that live in like a school
district. There's like a school for engineering.
There's a school for beauty school, for our carpentry.
There's even a school for retarded people, which is great.
I'm like who would send their kid to a school to learn, to be retarded.
I tried a new one. Um, retard.
It's tough. You're really walking a tough line there with the retard jokes.
I thought I could do it. I'll figure that one out.
Don't you worry. At the end of the weekend, that retard,
school's going to be cooking. Say, look,
I'm 85 days out of standup here folks. So, uh,
my Dick cannot get hard comedically. I'm working on it. All right.
By the way, I went to a gay wedding in January. So fun unwell. Any gay?
Any gays here?
Well now one gay guy to his case. All right.
Yeah. Yeah. Not one that is statistically impossible, but all right. Um,
right now there's some guy in the back, like,
should this be the time I come out?
Uh, yeah. Big fan, big fan of the gaze. You know, uh,
I read some article gay marriages raked up
3.8 billion for the country. How cool is that? Yeah.
Gays are to married with Blackboard of sports, you know,
take it to another level. You're the best at it.
All right. That's something there. I got to figure that one out. it.
Second show was a little rowdy, got heckled. A lot of drunk.
Some people wouldn't shut up and it was like, right.
I was right back in it. You know, you with the guy. You yell out.
If you call the horrible insult, his girlfriend tells him to shut up.
You're embarrassing. The, you know, classic, uh,
the beauty of Corona and the riots and all that is that we all know what I'm
talking about. You know, sometimes you tell a joke and somebody is like,
I don't know what it's like to have sex with a dog. You know,
why would I care about that? But Corona and everything, you can,
we're all on board. Then a lot of these will tack,
but that's what it's all about.
I wrote a whole new batch of jokes that I'm sure will eat their own up there.
We're such a weird country.
It's weird how we can only support one group at a time.
Like right now we're like trying to help black people two years ago.
It was me too. It was a women. What about women who still get with, yeah.
Now it's like, Hey, I'm a woman. I just got sexually assaulted. Hey,
shut up sister. We're on black. Now we can only do one of the time.
What about trans rights? That's so 2019 nerd. I got,
I'm just trying to help a buddy. All right. Oh, checks are coming around.
This audience has got the attention span of a net. Dick.
Saturday night, Dallas. We did two shows. Both were killer crowds are great,
great town, nice people,
good eggs at a couple of whiskeys. And, uh,
I should go out and hit the town, but I'm done. I'm gone in,
we got one show tomorrow and, uh, that'll do it for the weekend. And I'm saying,
I'm sad to end it. I used to look at comedy.
I got so routine it be. I flew up, flew out every weekend and
we got to do shows at night. Here's the hotel.
And now I didn't realize what I had. I love it. I take it.
I took it for granted. Now I'm grateful. I've hit the residents in.
We're going to bed.
I'll rub one out to a stormy Daniels and galled a
global life. You want to join?
Like as much as I.
On this, uh, this country of ours, I think it's still pretty good. You know,
you know, this country is great. 90 day. Fiance.
You ever seen this? When you look at some of the ghouls,
people are willing to just to get a taste of America. You're like,
we must have it. Pretty good. Huh?
Some is willing to let a guy with no neck inside of her just to get a taste of
Detroit. Like, all right. That's quite a nation. We got here.
We're getting there. We're getting there. Yeah. You guys are catching on.
You guys are all right. This crowds like anal takes a minute. You know,
after a while you're like, ah, I love it. Here we are in the, uh,
the hotel room, a lot of semen, some lotion,
somewhere. Best deodorant. Stand behind it.
Hey Corona. Now some businesses are opening with curbside pickup.
Prostitute said, Hey, we've been doing that the whole time. All right,
we'll try it. We'll give it a whirl. So, uh, hopefully there's a crowd tonight.
And uh, yeah, we'll, we'll yuck it up and probably offend somebody,
but it's sold out. Isn't it sold out? I didn't know that.
Oh my God. Well.
Let's go do some comedy
made this walk back pretty drunk.
When needed the rope for you now.
Dressed some of the going on in the world. So many good looking people here.
Well, not you, not you, but a couple of pretty healthy,
beautiful people in this town. You guys are underrated. Just beautiful ladies.
You know, like I traveled the country. There's a lot of,
a lot of fatties up there, you know? And we're fed country. That's all right.
You know, we're fed, we love food. We're obsessed with food.
All the factories in America have closed except cheesecake. Okay. That's it.
That's the only one that made it. Yeah.
These poor kids that got to go to school at home. Now they're all homeschooled.
You know, that's sad.
How long until a teacher in Florida has cyber sex with one of her students,
you know, what's going to happen. Any Jews here
either. There are no Jews here or Jews are like,
I'm not falling for that one again.
No, those days are over.
We did it. It's all over. I need more material. I suck.
Uh, I'm starting out killing. And then it just
goes right to the shitbox, but I'll get it together.
That's why you do these gigs to get more material. God it.
Hey, I wish you were my parents. Hey.
Hey, great frames. Hey, there he is. Hey,
thanks. Thanks God. It works
a good weekend. It's all over five shows in the bag,
a rusty as hell for a show,
but I'll tell you it all snaps right back in once you're up there and you're
feeling it, you're blowing baby. Woo. That was good to get back in there.
And now I feel like I got a cocaine bump and I got to go back to New York where
there's no comedy again. So I want to have withdrawals all over again,
but I got a little fix. So that was fun.
I got a lot of work done and tried some new jokes. Boy, it was great.
Just a tough time.
New special came out and I'm rusty and I'm doing new material.
So I'm all over the road. But, uh, that was great. Crowds were great.
I loved Texas. And now I got to fly back to New York.
So I'm gonna hit the bar and drank with the staff and the local comics.
One of the treats of doing comedies, hanging out with comics. So, uh,
let's go get drunk. Okay. Anyone else hard.